it is almost the end of our birthday
celebration with droozy
well ross put on his party outfit for
this last segment yes i would like this
thank you for noticing this is my third
change for you it's barry moore all
right it's your birthday and you deserve
it
i clocked every sweater you were wearing
thank you
this is definitely my favorite outfit i
agree so you
i look great thank you for noticing all
right and i'm
drew you're going to freak out over this
uh this next gift all right because our
girl drew you know we know her she loves
organizing
baskets and shelf liners she's a real
party animal
matching little bowls for everything on
her desk and her happy place is where
not not marie oh god sorry marie condo
is my happy place yeah
and and she's doing a collab with the
container store which we dorked out
over on drew's news oh yeah you love the
container store and guess what bffs
you are all getting a 150 credit
birthday okay we still have one more
gift
this one is for you though drew i want
to say hello to our final surprise
live from city hall please welcome the
mayor of west hollywood california
lindsay hi
i am great it's an honor and a pleasure
to be here with you today to celebrate
the one and only drew barrymore she grew
up here this is her hometown
we know this is uh a place where she we
hold her dear in our hearts and
um west hollywood is just so so proud of
the success
that drew has had and while many people
know us for fabulous gay men i myself
am partial to powerhouse women
mayor horvath i know there's a special
reason you wanted to be here for drew's
birthday and a special gift for her can
you tell us
yes so we have a very uh official uh
proclamation to make today here in the
city of west hollywood
allow me to read whereas drew barrymore
who grew up on north poinsetti a place
in west hollywood
is recognized as a celebrated actress
producer director
talk show host and entrepreneur and
whereas ms barrymore has a special
connection to the city of west hollywood
now therefore be it resolved that the
city council of the city of west
hollywood declared february 22
2021 drew barrymore day in west
hollywood hello
thank you i just officially had a heart
attack
all right having your own day is is
great but there's even more
mayor horvath what else do you have for
drew oh my god
today we would like to bestow upon you
ms barrymore
a key to the city of west hollywood
thank you for being such a wonderful
ambassador of our community
[Applause]
i'm very grateful i i loved growing up
in west hollywood
it was such a interesting community to
grow up in
it was really open-minded and
open-hearted and it set me up for
success in life
to accept people and care about them
ross what we forgot the cake we roll out
the cake
without a cake
oh it's a pretty one thank you it's so
beautiful
drew you are loved you are loved happy
birthday
and this is your show so you have to say
goodbye d
nice i can't believe you are here what
you did
for all of us when you started club
quarantine
made us feel like everything was gonna
be okay when we were the most scared
so thank you we love you drew i hope you
just are soaking it in
i hope you absorb it when you lay your
head down in bed tonight i hope all
these memories come rushing back and you
just
really feel it because it's your
birthday every day is drew barrymore day
definitely the best day of my life and
i really just want to say thank you to
chris and ember and jason and marianne
and
robin and leah mr daniel and everyone i
do that show with
like literally i wish i could be cooler
and keep it together but i can't
i don't know how i will ever
pay this back but i will live my life
paying it forward
thanks you guys
[Music]
come on
[Music]
you